the Joe Rogan experience damn you've got
a crazy [ __ ] and I laugh at every
inch of it - mm-hmm
well it's that's the only way you can
mean what you've done is you've done the
ultimate take a negative and turn into a
positive that's right that's right
but you mean you really have because
your your sense of humor is so [ __ ] up
because of your life that it's so funny
I mean that's why it works if you had a
cushy life and you were saying this [ __ ]
that you say it wouldn't be funny so it
wouldn't be no and that's one of the
things with my husband like when I was
sharing wedding like my kid's father
shot me and beat me you know most your
listeners kind of know who I am they
know my background and one of the things
when I started sharing my life my
husband had that protective mo he didn't
want me to you know he knew how negative
the world could be when I started to
share these stories so I could see what
he wanted to step in and protect me
right you know when people would judge
me and you know like I dropped out of
school in eighth grade when my husband
went to the military went on office he
had a mommy and daddy way better life to
me so he would always be there to like
be that protector like well sir oh they
think I'm stupid or they think I'm
missing and I just I just
he helped me grow a backbone didn't say
[ __ ] what people think about you because
it was so much screwed up stuff in my
head like one of the thing my mama
taught me about white people like I
didn't deal with white people
it was be honest I'm from the head it
was a police or the [ __ ] or the
caseworker my mama told me she said why
people are better than you never look
him in the eye another [ __ ] devil so
my whole life Joe Rogan I was scared of
white people and when I when I wrote the
book and I told the lady this when I
would see white people I immediately
looked down well that's what the slaves
used to do and that's what the book lady
told me and I was like I can't look him
in the eye
and then she was like why and I told her
the story and I told my husband stories
and he said pad
he said we're all the same your [ __ ]
mummy is stupid
[Laughter]
I used to shell a bit I said the only
difference between me and you white
woman is my titties is bigger than yours
but I was in I was in my late 20s when I
learned it because you like I when I
moved to Indianapolis I couldn't talk to
you I [ __ ] my words well stump
and I would immediately say I'm stupid
and I would look away and when I started
doing coming in Indianapolis and my fan
base turned white and I was like why the
[ __ ] y'all like me get away from me [ __ ]
out of you I just said that to myself
and my husband sent me down I was like
Pat we all the same your [ __ ] mom is
stupid I'm like we are and I was in my
late 20s
ever dealt with white people like I
dealt with them when I moved into that
community and I'm glad because it taught
me a lot as a young girl out of it out
of the inner city of Atlanta that we are
all the same the problem with the
problem with these countries we don't
[ __ ] talk no communication